in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to the
genius brain podcast for those of you
out there that are listening to that
snap that is not the sound of a condom
that is the sound of latex gloves [ __ ]
cuz we keep it as sane and the genius
beyond my face mask but I got them
gloves on and I got that hand sanitizer
in case anybody needs some probably all
carriers you know it's funny like when
we wear this even though we're trying to
protect ourselves from it people look at
us as if we already have it yeah it's
like if I already had I won't be coming
outside [ __ ] today I was I was out
there I was the grocery store this
morning
and I had to sneeze and I was like oh
don't you [ __ ] dare this is the world
you know the whole time so I was telling
you guys before so before we even did
our last ones like a couple days ago we
train I start have an allergy attack and
allergies run like really big in my
family with my mom and stuff so I start
having big allergies like congested nose
there it is and a scratchy throat so
like I ended up going to Seattle
everybody knows right and it was like
right in the middle of this I didn't
post anything because I didn't want
everybody [ __ ] message me why the
[ __ ] you out there Lana but every day I
was out there reading The Simpsons
reading The Simpsons reading the
symptoms one day I was out there we were
walking in the rain and [ __ ] I started
feeling really bad so I got really
nervous I was like [ __ ] I might be
catching this [ __ ] or I might and caught
these have it for sure but the next day
I woke up felt perfectly fine like I
felt even better honestly it's like I
did I felt better but then I still had
like the congestion and [ __ ] so I was
like [ __ ] and she the the fleet wasn't
nervous cuz she's out there she's in her
head she's like I'm getting it either
way I'm gonna get it somehow that I'm
out here I'm like alright so whatever
but so when I got back here my throat
was still like it's not it's not sore
but like my muscles around my neck like
my lymph nodes like when you have
allergy attack sore sore but I woke up
this morning
yesterday feeling better and I woke up
today feeling like almost completely
this was like telling this story right
now we're all sweating our ass we all
just started moving the couch over
that's okay
you were 102 no what am i long so now
that was the thing I was like I couldn't
breathe I was making sure like [ __ ] like
make sure I don't have a fever every day
I didn't I might you know everything
felt fine I wasn't coughing at and have
a runny nose but that was the thing what
you're saying it's like because of my
allergies like you know I have to clear
my throat and it's like doing that
especially out in Seattle and then over
here are you crazy I was trying my
hardest not to do it and I think that's
what started making my muscles tense up
because I needed to do it and I was
trying not to do I [ __ ] feel Vaughn
tweeted he said that coughing is a new
at night you know it turns heads dude
like for ro yeah but and it's so funny
cuz I'm like I'm over here like man give
a [ __ ] man give me corona advice on [ __ ]
but I want someone cause I'm like just
cough right here in the corner I'm
low-key kind of scared about to spray
all this all bro says the guy with all
the symptoms you literally said all the
symptoms had no symptoms it said a sore
throat my throat nice or if we'll just
jeopardize us right now man you don't
care about this thing I can't believe
you would do this to hey I'm not gonna
lie just want you guys to stay home so
I'm purposely getting understand losing
your [ __ ] minds though at home yeah
I'm getting I mean it's not like we
can't walk outside or do some [ __ ] right
but then you're my foot's [ __ ] so I
can't even walk for long places either
so I'm just staying at home doing
nothing I'm over you're shadowboxing in
front of Mario's face kind of stop in a
face-off yeah you saying why don't you
just go do it somewhere else is like you
the only person here if I sock you in
the face
I'm not crazy my first day back on
Sunday I was gonna go to the we had a
competition at the gym yeah I was like
you know I'm gonna be like safe for
everybody just in case I do have
something I'm not gonna go to a big
[ __ ] crowd and possibly if I had
something give it to somebody so I'm not
gonna go I was like cool I'll be able to
sleep in Sunday yeah normally I go to
work I didn't have work that day and
like towards the middle of the day I was
like y'all board it well you went to
smorgasbord right no there
my daddy try to get my jumpy but no and
then Monday yes all right yeah today's
Tuesday right yeah Monday I normally
drive to Simi Valley and no me have
clients throughout the the thing are you
still doing your home clients that see
me I'm not seeing him till next week so
but yeah maybe I had nothing to do how
old is your client 73
maybe you shouldn't see him for a couple
weeks well that was the thing it's like
he didn't really care he was I oh just
come he's like oh no no good sir and I
was like no if anything so like I got
out there on Thursday if anything I was
like I should be feeling something by
next like Sunday right so I told him was
I'm not seeing you this week at all I'll
let you know on Sunday to see how I feel
it's it's 14 days though I know that's
what I'm saying so but it's 2 to 14 days
yeah but you guys think it was gonna
gamble it is I'm dumb but don't gamble
it though don't get booked yes cuz he's
older dude anyway he's sick but we'll
see I know that's why I told him I was
like I'll text you on Sunday see I feel
if I feel fine like cuz he's the only
one like I'm not gonna lie like all of
us if we were to get it we're gonna be
fine but like he's the one person that
I'm like no I don't want if I have
anything like even even with him we have
to do this now if we have a cold or even
just a normal cold or a normal flu we
can't be around him because he's so sick
so this was before this is even before
all this yeah cuz his immune system he
has everything staged thing like two or
three kidney disease he has MS he's all
of his joints he has the craziest
craziest arthritis I've ever seen before
it was hanging by a thread maybe don't
see him for like the rest of the month
yeah I mean it's up to him I told him I
was like yo I'll text you Sunday I was
like no matter what cuz he told me to
come back I'm like no I'm taking off the
whole week I didn't tell him that until
Sunday because I knew he was gonna fight
with me yeah so I was like you know I'm
not gonna see you till next week I want
to see you now take me out of my misery
whatever you got pass it on to you I
wanted but anyway
but yeah I won't see him till next week
and I figured like you know anyways I
cancelled all my clients for this week
anyways on Sunday before knowing the gym
close yes that's all everybody I was
like hey just to be safe in precaution
right I'm not gonna see anybody this
week I was like I do feel fine you know
I had an allergy attack on Wednesday but
it's guy in a lot more technology of
tech like we've got dude I swear my
that's a corona attack dog you got the
RO no bro
if I got the Corona I'm happy because
this is going away then cuz I'm feeling
someone better but you know man said
over here that [ __ ] mutated twice
already in China bro it's gonna stay in
your system for so if safe you you say
you contracted it today from you cuz
you're actually the one that probably
boy got every gay I know so you got 14
days I think that's but at the same time
it's like do they really know it's 14
days you know I mean like I mean they
don't they don't even know I don't know
anything of the source or the origin for
it either because originally they were
saying that I don't want to say pay but
a lot of articles were going around
saying that it was from the from bats at
bars yeah I moved on from that saying
it's not from bats but they know that it
came from that Wuhan area like it's from
Chinese people specific and now they're
saying that it could possibly be from
the penguin right so a Pangolin is like
this scaled it's a scaly anteaters
basically what it is I'm gonna break it
down I've seen like Pangolin pictures
before a ping I thought you were single
penguins yeah now it's called the
Pangolin they say it's a Pangolin
there we go
so it's a Pangolin and apparently so
during like in the black market trade
like number one it's an exotic meat so
people do buy it doc is eating that I
don't know but on top of that I guess
the scales are used for medicinal
purposes so that's why it's like a rhino
horn for like yeah hi it's like I don't
know what it's supposed to cure but it's
like some kind of Eastern medicine ship
where they use the scales and there and
they thought it was from that because I
guess the penguin had a strand of co vyd
however I forgot what it was exactly I
mean I could look it up right now but
there's like some kind of it's not
conclusive to the point where they know
for a fact that
COBIT came from the Pangolin so they
don't know how
started and um and I think some people
were thinking that it was like some kind
of biological warfare weapon but that's
very highly unlikely because of how
advanced and how crazy the [ __ ] is which
they came I just heard another one today
so I've read 9/11 was an inside job I
know I've read so many [ __ ]
conspiracy theories right so here's one
of them that I was like yo this [ __ ]
gotta be true it oh right they said like
a does everybody does anybody remember
when North Korea was like hey I got a
present for you guys and nothing
happened and then supposedly obviously
we're never gonna know because they're
not gonna tell [ __ ] but they've had one
case and they executed that person but
ever ever since then they haven't had
anything I don't like that's how they
get down though exactly but know what
I'm saying it so that was there that was
that person conspiracy that this is what
their present was to the world that they
were saying yeah
you think North Korea is that that that
gangster way though if that was the
present that they gave I'm pretty sure
Kim jong-il and Kim jong-un would be
talking about it right now it's like
what's that [ __ ] I'd be bragging
I give it to you like a beast one I
heard one today someone was kind of
saying like they think they think it was
made in China purposely to like kind of
[ __ ] with the whole world to kind of I
don't they were explaining some all this
[ __ ] us in there listening to them as
they got into it basically saying it was
gonna [ __ ] with who's on me some person
I'm not gonna say name and that yeah
that it was gonna [ __ ] with the economy
basically stop it so when it was gonna
help China's money out because
supposedly like they're almost like free
of it right they've cured a lot of
people with it in that type of stuff but
everybody else is struggling with it it
was supposedly gonna help build China's
economy up in that type of stuff I feel
like they're already kicking ass what
the [ __ ] else do they need from this
[ __ ] yeah that's what I was thinking in
my head when he's saying that am i all
right here's know why they call it the
corner virus no so apparent this is from
this is from TIF it's from a Mexican
chef shout-out to TIFF she's out in the
front lines with she works at hospital
anyway I was gonna say oh yeah so I get
I guess when they look at the disease
under microscope a Mexican dude drinking
a beer yeah yeah it's actually logo says
no I'm this way yeah
it looks like a crown and then a crown
of Spanish means Corona crazy that's why
they call it Corona yeah
that's ridiculous I know it's like why'd
you guys translate to Spanish you know I
know Tsingtao
disease welcome to Tsingtao disease man
it's it's weird because I'd be wrong
lateral you know because like I own a
bunch of food businesses now and now I'm
seeing all these like small mom-and-pop
businesses suffer from the [ __ ] because
number one la effectively what two days
ago or was it yesterday things it was
yesterday on Monday they shut down all
restaurants all gyms any places the
gatherings above a hundred people and
now I hear it's down to 50 people yes
not even a hundred is 50 now they're
even saying if you're gathering more
than ten yeah no no boy no because
that's how contagious it is obviously
it's like dude if Kevin Durant gets it
what are you doing you know this social
distancing thing not everybody's taking
it serious because we were just talking
about how in Florida like what's through
there all on the beaches
even on Bourbon Street and first of all
number one if you guys have never been
to Bourbon Street before out in a
Louisiana no won't come about not
nollans I'm sorry I'm not at all and I'm
so I've been to Bourbon Street nollies
know on a Tuesday and that [ __ ] is
packed on a Tuesday and Bush should be
[ __ ] working
do you pravesh huh I ate everything out
dairy and [ __ ] no but when I was out
there like I'm talking about when you
see all these movies where they talk
about how crazy Barbary Street is they
have a bunch of spots where there's a
like strip clubs yeah and so there's
dudes out there with flyers trying to
get people to come in high school the
first time I was ever on Bourbon Street
it was for a brand deal for this hotel
and I won I wanted to go out and go eat
some [ __ ] it's two walks up to me and
this is how he knows his strip club he
goes so bro you like [ __ ] or what oh oh
yeah yes but excuse but there was it was
packed on a Tuesday night and he told me
like Tuesday nights the slowest [ __ ]
day so I could imagine how pop in that
place is and how much Coronas there
mm-hmm do you think is still poppin now
or what I don't know but they had that
video clip of the guy of the cops going
through telling people to go home
because they're endangering other
people's lives but they weren't doing
that [ __ ] in Florida people floor don't
give a [ __ ] man if you like people don't
think it's a real thing they all think
cuz honestly I'm like a couple like a
couple weeks ago your boy was like yeah
Corona buyer
whatever but now it's getting to the
point where your boys believe in you no
vanessa hudgens got some flack just to
get it to well she was she was I mean
here's the weird part right so Vanessa
Hudgens went online on Instagram I
believe I think it was a story or a post
but let me just find the quote that's my
thing obviously I like I said I know
it's serious and it's a thing but it's
like I think that's why people are
taking it that way because people that
are like my age are our age there's not
like a death rate really for you right
it's out of sight out of mind yeah so
but what why it needs to be taken
serious is because I could have it and I
could walk by an older person and
they're both and then I give it to them
and then imagine they get sick and pass
away right now it's like so that that's
why I needs to be taken the more it's
the more it's happening then the the
less the people are aware of it and kind
of taking it seriously the more we're
gonna be stuck in this goddamn position
where we can't worry it's that quote
this Vanessa Hudgens real quick people
were [ __ ] pissed at her so this is
she says she goes yeah till July sounds
so basically the I guess they released
some information saying that this might
be a serious quarantine till about July
or August which is a very long time yeah
she goes um yeah till July sounds like a
bunch of [ __ ] shoutouts to Vanessa
Hudgens ha boos were popping wait when
her news came out when she was underage
or of age think she was of age cuz she
was already like 17 or some [ __ ] right
okay well if she was of age poppin if my
disgusting she said of a potential corny
to her 38.4 million followers she goes
I'm sorry but like it's a virus I get it
like I respect it but at the same time
I'm like even if everybody gets it like
yeah people are gonna die which is
terrible but like inevitable all the
like all the likes that David said is
actually I wasn't I better only have a
hundred forty characters it seems like a
lot more you know and and the funny
thing about this [ __ ] is - is like
number one I kind of I don't am I
surprised like why the [ __ ] are you guys
surprised yeah some people put these
celebrities on this room I'm not saying
that what she said was smarter or
anything saying is dumb as [ __ ] you
expect if I don't I don't expect any
better still people yeah there's no like
but the other thing about this it's just
like it sounds so privileged dude you
know exactly what it is just like man
you you don't get it huh
is it Vanessa Hudgens Mexican some sort
of like to watch you [ __ ] talking
like a wet up [ __ ] I don't want it late
but I basically play I understand but if
you didn't who banessa Hudgens is just
by the name you've like oh she's white
for sure
I guess she put out a public apology and
she was like I'm so sorry for a lot of
people who miss and she's like I'm very
like sorry about seats but what she said
misinterpreted it's like is that apology
though because I can understand if you
didn't understand the gravity of the
situation you know blah I mean she was
[ __ ] yeah it's pretty insensitive
like she don't get a pass I'm just
saying like ice whoa dude why are you
defending what's your name he had it but
I saw her naked so it's a trade-off
okay just Alba got it whatever [ __ ]
named me that dude ha hey he had that
[ __ ] when he was on hot ones you saw a
little cop see all the views with their
like I already found out he had a corona
virus but it's like dude if Tom if all
these people are all getting it people
and [ __ ] but if it's regular people I
mean that's cuz every I honestly
personally think everybody's gonna get
it and the whole thing is like with that
basketball player right now eventually
he had zero zero decent man symptoms
yeah a lot of people apparently yeah and
it's know that this is this disease came
out cuz now I know what asymptomatic
means I still don't even know what that
is like you guys are kind of explaining
well it's like if you say somebody's a
sexual that means that he doesn't have a
preference easy to find women mail
anything attracted a lot of something
again that's what on me know I know a
guy that's [ __ ] asexual is the
weirdest [ __ ] oh yeah so like what does
he say when he's asexual because I've
always I'm fascinated by that ok you
know what let me just preface this with
some [ __ ] he never said he was I know
but it's because he's a man he said it
with his eyes though I've known this guy
for many [ __ ] years right 10 plus
years now and you know we've kicked it
we talked we used to hang out a lot this
guy nothing guys girl so we were
watching TV this is an arcade town my my
k-town apartment off of Wilshire this
big old spot that everybody's to come
and kick it at so we were watching some
[ __ ] right and it was a scene where this
guy and his girl was making out this
guy's a grown-ass man two years older
than me he goes I know you was gay gay
turn on a video we're watching some
other [ __ ] right and then it was like
these two gay dudes kissing and he goes
what do you like that what you like and
now that we have all this like binary
stuff or whatever I'm trying to figure
out like okay maybe he's like somewhere
in between but the guy is not motivated
by any type of sex whatsoever he is
definitely asexual he must be so
productive
he isn't though I don't know what his
motivation in life is because we've been
all trying to figure out because he's
such a odd but he's hyper talented at
what he does too by the way
but one time we offered him we had to
drop off this package for it was for
Comic Con and he was gonna go there
anyways and this is how weird this guy
is I think this is why I can't figure
him out he's not motivated by sex women
whatever not even money because when he
was going to comic-con let's say you're
going to comic-con right you're already
gonna go there and I go hey Nick I'm
gonna give you 500 bucks to drop this
package off to a client since you're
already gonna go there just drop it off
at their desk I'll give you 500 bucks
what do you say yeah he said no why
we're like why he goes it's too much
work I'm like I want to what the [ __ ] I
just said I would give you 500 bucks
like the ultimate hustle right go to a
place that you're already going to and
the booth that he's going to is right
there and he still said no I can't
figure this guy out
either way long story short that fool
don't like [ __ ] or I would have made a
post be like hey I'm about to be
delivering packages
deliver packages only $500 you would
have took out that 500 and exchanged for
just once though the craziest thing
they'll Trump the Trump yeah was oh yes
I'm at it's like I know virus or some
yeah he said it's like we'll all
survives a child bro this guy dude
literally have you seen the video clip
of him talking about he's like people
always ask me how I know so much about
the corona virus like he's talking about
the corona virus and he's literally
bringing himself into it talking about
like how much he knows he's like I
probably should have been a scientist or
something people say I'm a naturalist
because that has it he probably does
have it if it does if it's this
contagious he was in contact with the
Brazilian from hell I mean that fool has
it he has to I mean it's just weird that
he would put I mean he's so [ __ ] dumb
he doesn't understand he just like
greenlit a bunch of Asian people it's
like come on hey or he goes exactly
maybe you guys can't really me this cuz
I honestly don't know what is with these
like lines at the gun stores and [ __ ]
why are people buying well for sure so
uh well ever since this whole [ __ ]
happen right people are worried about a
quarantine they're worried about a
shortage of food so when there's a short
marshal people are scared of are so a
lot of people are gonna go [ __ ] crazy
they're gonna start robbing people so
now people are trying to get guns so in
case some [ __ ] pops off you can pop off
back at the governor for here keeps
saying and they keep saying like there's
not a shortage of there isn't there's no
shortage yeah these stores have a
specific amount of stuff they're able to
get for that day they get it and then
it's bought out within like the [ __ ]
first hours of people as oh I everything
yeah crazy well thank you yeah you got
to go to the ethnic markets I was just
telling him today I was like that secret
out man hey Loki I was driving by over
in where I used to live in Temple City
or it's kind of like El Monte area on
Baldwin there's a lot of those buildings
like that and I'm ia that's mark is
these are big guys buildings and lines
weren't that long so so the other thing
the other thing about like by artha and
all these other stores by artha
this it's a Mexican supermarket Josh a
shout out shout out it's like Mexican
Whole Foods go but
it's in Pasadena but they're opening
their store earlier to seniors and like
pregnant women things like that
exclusively so they need get all their
stuff and they can get the hell out and
they can be safe which is dope but at
the same time it's like I went in there
today and I thought I was gonna see a
big ol line walked in shelves were
pretty much stocked you know they
usually have hot foods but they didn't
say they were selling it or being
[ __ ] ridiculous out there just
finding people for toilet paper and [ __ ]
you know at the end of the day we still
have running water so yeah take the [ __ ]
you could always just go into the
bathtub watch your ass sign any people
with the days are like a [ __ ] yeah I
hear they're turning that into a black
market - no we're selling that for like
five my brother was right so I was
literally talking with my friend
yesterday I was like I feel like big
days are probably like sold out at
stores he's like nah now they're not I
talked to my brother last night at
FaceTime him with my niece and nephew
and he was like hey I think after all
this shit's done I'm gonna buy a bad day
I was like yeah I think that's probably
like the best he's like yeah I went to a
couple stores are sold out everywhere I
was like [ __ ] knew they were gonna be
sold out there was that guy who bought
like 17,000 bottles of sass and he was
trying to upsell he was saying he was
upselling up to like $25 a bottle or
some [ __ ] what a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
heard that forcing him then don't do
what $5.00 what happened what happened
was is when he was buying all of it from
what I read [ __ ] he was buying all of it
claiming he was gonna donate it buys all
of it then tries this price gouging on
Amazon Amazon shuts down his account and
then he gets contacted by the police
saying they were gonna investigate him
for price cop that's a fine and then
then he donated it so he's trying to
make it's kind of rubbish I don't make
you see a piece on me hero I'm like
[ __ ] you only [ __ ] donated it
because you got shut down in the count
I'm gonna investigate you that's the
[ __ ] and but like all this type of stuff
- the same with the old people like my
grandma's actually dealing with this
[ __ ] right I was just telling you guys
she she said she has like two rolls of
toilet paper right now so my mom's about
to mail her out toilet paper because she
can't go to the [ __ ] source number
one cuz they're telling her stay in
right cuz she's she's 71 now so the
talent is staying in and she says she's
been to a couple stores already she
can't find any and I posted that story
on my on my Instagram last night about
me having the [ __ ]
those soups right I went to finally
found some soups yeah she messaged me
she's like hey can you send me something
I can't find any of these anywhere I'm
like damn is like wall-e about like six
and I already ate three of them but if
your grandfather's oh my god yeah a
bunch you have a guy that buys like
three were three weeks worth of
quarantine food and he's gone in two
days no those bag the chips I come with
a bunch of small ones I bought like four
things a chunky noodle soup I bought two
things of the raviolis I bought
that's nearly bad enough food for you
about six of the soups that's Alex's
breakfast three of the soup that alone I
two of the chunky soups already I one of
the raviolis I've already ate like six
of those bags of chips um I probably
need go back this though go to other
Chinese Chinese they have all the Robins
I know so there's a little spot over
here actually so one of my friends told
me about it it's like a little pharmacy
thing and he's like yeah we got a [ __ ]
ton of them but they're like to hire in
I guess like Asian style they have like
the Asian with you you can get you can
get all that [ __ ] like I got a bunch of
Indomie the mega ring noodles oh I got
sick first of all I got enough noodle
packets to last me up until [ __ ]
December 4 oh yeah you boys been eating
them like like nothing yeah a bit even
all of them so I went and but the only
thing is that these were like almost 2
bucks each so you go to go to the
Chinese market you can get them for like
I was telling TIFF about this yesterday
I got it for I got like a pack of eight
for like 250 Dan that would have saved
me a [ __ ] one yeah
or I have somebody send me the link to
that right then yeah well we can just
we'll just go yeah cuz I'll send some to
my grandma cuz she straight up DM me
today she's a I can find me some ground
balls on Instagram yeah my and my
grandma's not a normal grandma right so
I just feel like stereotypical right
grandmas like oh hey she did they stay
home they couldn't even know how that
should make sense I've never seen a old
person DM anything so like so like right
the stereotypical grandma they stay home
they cook cookies and they're like oh
they [ __ ] give you milk or whatever
the [ __ ] they get right
let you [ __ ] your grandma is weird dude
you don't like regular grandmas they
just get people milk dawg I don't but
that I that I can't talk anyway
wait so this is my grandma right
remember the movie knocked up yeah yeah
she's the one that took me to see that
in theaters I did she thought that [ __ ]
was funny as [ __ ] she says let's see
you're laughing that with me right she's
on Instagram she like responds to my
stories and do that's lit you do signai
this is how Jima Graham is right 69
years old I feel like I want to get a
tattoo my grandma got a [ __ ]
tattoo in our living room for my tattoo
artists back in Arizona yeah she got a
[ __ ] butterfly tattoo and then she's
like I want to get another one my mom
your grandma is hella young yeah she's
71 now she's [ __ ] young as hell man
well say well my parents like everybody
Church so I turned 27 this year my dad
turns 50 and my mom turns 49 Wow
dad I'm the youngest of the three boys
and then my mom I have a younger sister
on my mom's cuz she got remarried
she's 14 this year and then my oldest
brother turns 30 and my middle brother
turned 28 this year
you get everything you ever get said
when you think about your grandmother
like she can't get food and stuff yeah
I'm sad that's why my [ __ ] I write what
she told me yeah I'm sad because I call
me I'm sad what the [ __ ] yeah I spray
all the [ __ ] hands in industry but
did you see that video of that one like
Asian grandma getting chased by that
dude with sanitizer he's like you gotta
[ __ ] wash your hands ling-ling and
[ __ ] like that actually piss me if I saw
in the store I probably would fight
somebody do I gotta show you that [ __ ]
that show so one okay so one of the
homies okay I love you grandma if you
watch the a she like that she I sent her
the link like send me the link sweetie
Oh watch it
that's awesome love my gram so one of
the homies Ricky he's a trainer at the
gym his client mark who's a good friend
of the gym he said he was in Culver City
and he saw I guess yeah I think it was
actually his friend his friend was some
like Asian dude obviously well they're
at Trader Joe's some guy some white dude
chases this guy around the store with
sanitizer and Lysol and start spraying
him in the corner
what like it in Culver City yeah bro
this is why I thought they were
people were buying guns cuz I the the
stores I passed by were like in Asian
neighborhoods and was a lot of Asian
people lined up so I thought that was a
thing and I thought maybe that's why I
think we're buying too like because I
feel like especially Trump saying right
this Chinese virus I can already see
people going crazy trying to like beat
the [ __ ] aegeon people just because and
stuff so I thought maybe that's why they
were haven't you had any experiences I'm
a really large guy nobody nobody just
gonna come up to say that [ __ ] until
they hear my soft ass voice but when I'm
quiet though I look mad like I I don't
think I've had any experiences yet but
I've definitely got probably not going
to because your ears know now but I
don't know what that means though most
people a lot of people do nowadays I'm a
small frail man so you are actually very
small you're very weak and pity as well
this keeps going
also your teeth fall out your skin is
very soft meat may be mean jay Park will
do do watch this [ __ ] video though
this is like literally the video of the
guy chasing ah this is gonna piss me off
dude
it's like chasing her how do you funny
you know what's [ __ ] up though is that
like she's still like smiling and
laughing and then it won't hit her til
later she was like oh [ __ ] this guy was
being a [ __ ] ass yeah it's weird too
because like I'm like I like seeing
these videos only because I want to see
what comical said I want to see what the
demographic is that finds it funny and I
want to see who the Democrat guys I
guess that doesn't find it who finds a
funny find it funny and I think like the
odd part is it's like I hate this
because when I see the comments the the
reaction to something terrible and
racist is for other people to come back
and say really racist [ __ ] yeah he's
black it's like yeah you know two wrongs
don't make a right yeah bro doesn't
cancel out two wrongs don't make a white
oh
thanks man thanks man do you not a man
who wants to make a wide range a night
yeah dude that's [ __ ] up that's that
[ __ ] looky what I talked about last time
when I get in my feelings like yeah like
that shivers you think about your grand
get our okay we can actually touch your
boy was in his face like haha hey Loki
how hard has it been to not touch your
face
just cuz you're not supposed to like all
of a sudden I'm getting these itches on
my face yeah come on you know when we
were podcasting the moment I hit that
button my eye was itching
don't touch your face especially I work
today cuz I was like moving [ __ ] around
and we were like fixing bins like my I
like my face kept itching on my somebody
if somebody had pinkeye that we
encountered oh [ __ ] yeah double pinkeye
this was like couple weeks ago but as
soon as I realized this person that
pinkeye double pinkeye your boy's eyes
were itchy as [ __ ] that's the same thing
like if you see bugs like a say you're
in your room and you see a bug on the
floor you kill it all of a sudden you're
like you know why you saw up here dude
is because of where you live so most
people don't see cockroach sometimes
that's my only company 30 cockroaches a
[ __ ] another like a 1 alert when umberto
come to the waffle it's like a [ __ ]
Punk oh hey
Oberg don't have all the chips now dog
they Beach in there unless she wasn't an
F lay with me about the 30-pack form
listen if somebody's common still on
this post he goes one person wrote he
ain't do nothin y'all stop this [ __ ]
it's like damn something [ __ ] 88 but
these comments are going you know name
and some people are like you know just
those are the ones with like 92 comment
replies for sure you know you already
know your [ __ ] hood is [ __ ] when you
go this is this is a side you know
somebody's hood is when you go to the
Instagram and in there caption there's
72 different emojis yeah like for some
reason that's like a good thing they're
like I'm a king with twins who are the
real
gorilla [ __ ] with a gorilla and a monkey
and then like all this other [ __ ] and
they have like I love surround r.i.p
some [ __ ] like I'm around my cars they
have those emotions another comment
somebody wrote but if a [ __ ] did
this to a black person during the Ebola
outbreak
y'all be mad as [ __ ] and y'all still
continue to say that black people can't
be racist and this is from a young black
woman yeah I mean that is a good
comparison I guess all right good point
yeah I feel like everybody Loki's little
racist for Rho but it's like it's like
you do [ __ ] like this bro it's like
you're obviously you're asking for it
yeah you know like you're you're putting
yourself on a platform doing fucked-up
[ __ ] and like at the end of the day this
isn't gonna do anything you know like
he's trying to be funny he's not getting
a point across and but it's dumb it's
like I'll that's how stupid you are that
that's their entertainment like oh my
entertainment is let me find a agen lady
that's minding her own [ __ ] business
and we go try and [ __ ] with her and make
a stupid [ __ ] video that's the only
reason why they did this if they if they
for real felt that way there wouldn't be
a video well it's also like these are
the same kids in high school that were
messing with like you know the
special-needs kids maybe they save kids
man like this is this this is the thing
and I and I want to bring people back on
this is because number one like there's
a there's there's a it's problematic
when people see this and they think that
this is a representation of that
person's culture because that person's
yes number one is not number two the
here's the thing and I'm not this is not
a defense and I have to say this because
it's the same thing that was going on
about Vanessa Hudgens yeah this guy is a
dumb [ __ ] yeah you don't know no
anybody
people are gonna do dumb [ __ ] it's not
excusable yeah but to sit there and be
enraged okay and I'm gonna use this word
very lightly because I found out only on
this podcast and this is the words you
should use but when a [ __ ] person
does something [ __ ] that's what a
[ __ ] person does yeah you can't
expect anything else you don't get mad
at a [ __ ] for doing [ __ ] things yeah
you know what I mean so I can't get into
my feelings and look at this video and
be like he should know better actually
he doesn't because he's [ __ ] dumb
yeah if anything else if you go to this
guy's page you'll could listen to his
music his music is trash as well yeah so
it's like it's he doesn't have good
taste in music he's not a good rapper
yep you see what have Bill Gates did
that you know
bill gayde bill gates do that they'll be
all that crazy lot must do this and put
I might be in my feelings about this
[ __ ] I'm like what do you think it feels
like well I was trying to see if I could
sanitize someone on a pilot but it's
like that that video reminds me of the
one with the guy the Asian guy with the
bottles right it's like the same [ __ ]
yeah it's like it's like a hood
[ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] with him
obviously like you won't expect that
from anybody else except first up
[ __ ] cuz when you see that when
you see that video the first thing that
pops in your head for most people is
like racist but the other thing pops in
your head is oh this guy's [ __ ] dumb
like he's a dumb piece of [ __ ] whatever
you know it is what it is see case in
point I just clicked on his [ __ ]
Instagram it's it there's a what is this
there is a black eye emoji with a
hundred sign with the Shaka sign with a
time sandé time thing and it says big
with two g's and sleepy zzzz he has he
has a video of him in his bathroom with
a shotgun and a pistol pointing at the
phone that's is a hood rat hood right so
it is what it is right so I'm saying
like I'm trying to figure out what those
emojis means like I'm a black man I keep
some 100 Shaka for life time is up it is
sleep and know what I hate it that's a
big thing you know being and like
wrapping around these people it's like
the whole thing it's like hey I don't
sleep I'll sleep like this why not I see
some of my friends through this dad
stuff awesome people
Oh ma'am tired but you know I don't
sleep like [ __ ] sleep trust me you're
not doing anything where you don't need
to not be sleeping trust me like y'all
that the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] is like
when I see people who say [ __ ] like
they're like the hustle never stops I
always be grinding inside the last why
you still poor exact point I don't ever
sleep like babies also our [ __ ] late
on your card [ __ ] payment your also
hey Tasha credit score yeah if you sleep
your [ __ ] brain will be smarter
you'll be able to [ __ ] grind better
it's like every time when I was on
Instagram and I know certain people you
know who are Instagram models and I was
seeing [ __ ] and then
and they would put up a post saying like
this job is so hard I you know working
never say first of all you don't know
what hard work is even for the stuff
that I do I don't say it's it's it's not
incredibly difficult in terms of the
output right for somebody who has to be
on their feet and work all the time at
home so when somebody says like I've
been working all day and I know what you
do when you just post ass pictures I'm
glad you're getting money do your thing
but you can't sit there and tell people
who work 24/7 say I'm grinding and
working everyday yeah like I know what
the [ __ ] you do [ __ ] I'm in your
industry I say I'll ask pictures all the
time even our job like I we work a lot
but I don't know how you felt about my
job our job is fairly [ __ ] easy yeah
training people there's definitely
there's definitely times where you get
people that require a lot more yeah and
I feel like I might have more of those
people but in general like like I enjoy
I enjoy my time with my client easy job
at Cisco and it's very it's very small
spurts like say you have I have four
clients a day and say just luckily
they're all ours right that's four hours
of work yeah and really like what it is
half of the time is you set [ __ ] up they
just want to talk most of the time so
you're doing it but like I understand
like when I was working I was just
talking to someone today I kind of
forgot how much I was working like when
I first got here cuz I didn't know
anybody so for me my whole thing was
like I'm we fill in time with work cuz I
don't know like I don't want to go home
and just be home all day and not do
anything right but like at one point out
here I was working at Best Buy a
part-time and then I was doing dog
walking which dog walking is actually
hard I just had the funniest [ __ ]
picture of you walking dogs man yeah
she's hilarious
low-key fun and we used to take packs of
like six and all of our dogs are good
they didn't have to put on leash we used
to go to like Deb smelling they used to
run around listening to us but that's
one of the hardest jobs because that's a
job you cannot call in sick if you're
sick you still have to walk the dogs cuz
these people are paying you because
they're at work for ten hours all that
type of stuff you can't you can't be
sick you guys still gotta take the dogs
I was doing that Best Buy and personal
training so I remember during that time
my schedule was so tight like I couldn't
really change her on anything
I couldn't a client wanna switch this
tell me but I can do because I have to
go do this at this time and this at this
time I need to make sure I can drive
here your car how much do people pay for
dog walking companies they're like yeah
the question 25 bucks 30 bucks a walk or
some [ __ ] like that
you know like some vibes 30 minute walks
yeah our walk sometimes it's like that I
just walk for the [ __ ] of it maybe I
should just walk people's dogs hey dude
suppose I don't know it was my friend's
company that was doing this I don't
really remember like fully but yeah I
think some some people that depends on
how many dogs are coming too so like if
it's like the only if it's only one dog
it's obviously more expensive right yeah
but like if I'm gonna bring them into a
pack and it all depends to like if they
want me to hike if they wanted us to
hike the dog that means I would have to
go pick up the dog bring them to a
mountain hike oh they wanted you to take
the dogs on hike so that's what we were
doing
[ __ ] that so there's a couple times like
they're out there looking I would go
just to the house I would love to do
that so I would just go to the house and
walk the dog around the neighborhood
right for an hour you know we always
take pictures send it to the owner so
they know I want to play with all the
dogs yeah and then dream other times we
would take the dogs with the pack to
like a mountain and go hiking [ __ ] right
and it was cool and all but at the end
of the day it's like you know I I
remember the time I bought a golf like a
Volkswagen Golf and he was so stoked
about it and this was a good job
opportunity with me I started doing it
why was that Best Buy but it eventually
led to me being able to quit Best Buy
because I started making good money off
of it whole car permanently filled with
dog hair permanently smelt like dog and
it just kind of [ __ ] up everything so
I kind of was like man but that [ __ ] was
fun yeah you can make good money off it
but it's something that you cannot quit
from and so like I was doing that and I
remember back in Arizona it was worse
because that in Arizona was the time
when I was actually on my feet I used to
work at Burger King and Best Buy and I
was full-time at both at one point how
big were you when you were working at
Burger King that's where I put on all my
weight thank you it I don't know a
single person that worked for a
fast-food they didn't gain like 30
pounds dude no I swear that then the
whole thing is like because the food's
right there so you know just eating
fries and [ __ ] and stuff like that and
you would like you make them raise these
[ __ ] meals for ya Oh what's what's
that what's the meal that you made all
the time Burger King like tell me tell
me your top favorite foods when you
worked at Burger cuz a homie who worked
at McDonald's would all
tell me like his [ __ ] that he always did
that's why I started putting hashbrowns
into the sausage Egg McMuffins so Loki
right so there's two there's two of them
right so the [ __ ] fish sandwich from
Burger King is actually straight fire
right better than the flail fish dude
I'm telling you I know [ __ ] I know
they had a fish so this is what I do cuz
normally they'll pull extra tartar sauce
on it right how whatever so [ __ ] that
get the bun just a but right put some
lettuce on it I think I put a little bit
of mayo on it just a little bit put the
lettuce on there tomato cheese on top of
that and some ketchup all over that show
what ketchup that [ __ ] that's okay what
would you say already SLA P my god
fascist but what's what's that red sauce
called again ketchup though you said
yeah you said it so weird
ketchup ketchup you said catch up
walking dogs here like yo ketchup day we
used to rap use my ketchup hey so you
want to catch up whatever put that [ __ ]
up on there and then Stowers
go in there be like I want to play it or
not to play fish [ __ ] that doesn't
account for me don't you go to Burger
King you say I want the fish the big
fish but lettuce a little bit of mayo
cheese tomato spray some ketchup on it
that she slap the other one was the you
knows long chicken sandwiches at this
other yeah that's the only thing I liked
the burger bread and check this out so
here you go ready so normally they put
mayo hope you're taking notes but they
put mayo lettuce and that's it that's
all they put on it right low-key what
you got to do is you can still put Mayo
you put lettuce
honey mustard they have a honey mustard
sauce there but that [ __ ] apps for some
reason that honey mustard with that type
of chicken they use for that type of
[ __ ] I don't know what it is that stuff
dipped in the honey mustard that [ __ ]
well you should do trash food reviews
dude yeah Rockets your boy would do like
heinous terrible thing how long did you
work did you got fired I think your fire
dude I left I left on good terms
I've never been fired from a job yet
what they fire you for though
[Laughter]
no and I still got one more though oh
[ __ ] okay last one what we would do
what's the [ __ ] the tender grill
sandwich what's that it's a like a
grilled chicken one yeah it's the
grilled chicken sandwich so what I used
to do is because they used to put on a
different type of bread I used to put it
on normal whopper bread even though it'd
be a little too big for it but [ __ ]
you know I'm saying that one I would put
mustard these are like deep cuts
I'm sorry not mustard [ __ ] mayo
lettuce cheese tomatoes and I put
ketchup and then barbecue sauce all over
that [ __ ] the barbecue sauce they had
there dude that was my [ __ ] but yeah
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good and then we
used to always [ __ ] around and make some
weird [ __ ] oh one more thing right did
this [ __ ] was like good we used to have
the little [ __ ] slushy machines uh-huh
so we used to do coke and cherry yeah we
also had we did milkshakes and like ice
cream and [ __ ] you put a little bit of
coke first you go to ice cream you put a
little bit of ice cream in it coke ice
cream cone ice cream that shapeless hope
you like 400 goddamn what the for my
400-pound money dude dude some of the
times receipt that we should have that
stacker sandwich remember that [ __ ] yeah
that [ __ ] had the most calories out of
every Fussell you just [ __ ] your pants
all the time
dude I'm telling you but that [ __ ] was
good and it helped me out a lot too
because you know Arizona at the time I
was making 725 when I first started at
Burger King right so you're making zero
money so but I had free food all the
time and I remember when I started I was
doing Burger King 5 a.m. just as just
for a small moment of time Burger King 5
a.m. to 1 and then Best Buy 2 to 10 so I
would go from job to job and I did that
for a little bit both full-time but it
was good because I'll still broke his
[ __ ] because I didn't know how to spend
money and he worked at Burger King like
what was your job everybody through
everything I was technically an
assistant like manager but at those
types of job search you go there there's
19 assistant managers were system yeah
so basically right I wasn't looking
Dwight there and so but yeah so like it
was saved me a lot though because I
could eat free food all the time so it
was even to the point where I wasn't
even working that day I could still
drive and I would
go into the kitchen make food and leave
like no one I don't think you're
supposed to do that bro not but no I
[Laughter]
know my pops love that [ __ ] too right
because when I used to get off I used to
text and be like hey dad I'm leaving you
want some yeah I'll just take some small
though I'm not that hungry in my art
what you want can I get a large double
whopper meal onion rings and then can
you bring me another extra cheeseburger
and then one of those apple pies I'm
like full that's not small [ __ ]
so I'm leaving with like a whole thing I
just got my dad [ __ ] I would
never call them they beat my [ __ ] dad
is still 36 hey my do know but that was
fun that was fun but I used to get the
hook-up their dog we sad little thing
hey I'm talking about two fuck-ups only
job that Burger King done they have this
little blue card you swipe and you press
like manage your mill or enjoy a meal
right employee meals 50% off manager 75%
my old spot they would go swipe employee
50% off swipe manager you get 75 I think
that's that's how it goes at all
restaurants like because when I worked
at Johnny Rockets it was like that too
bro people I remember this one girl she
would all the lot of the people I worked
with that giant rockets were very
terrible at their job there was very few
people because it was like fi I'm
fighting a fire now okay yeah I could
tell what fired you to me bro keep it G
your boy was the best server there I
don't like cuz I took my job seriously I
took that [ __ ] like I would run the
tables because also if you there was
there'd only be two servers for the
whole restaurant and the obviously the
other server I would usually work with
was kind of like trash so most the time
I'd be running around all over the place
and your boy would be kind of sweaty
running to like table the table and
people kind of respected that and they
would give me a little extra tip your
boy got tipped out a lot oh man I I
never been in a food service industry
where why I own him now but I've never
done the waitering part yeah I don't
think I can with my personality I got
too much attitude yeah cuz honestly you
have to be passive like never get a
[ __ ] tip to save my life yeah because
if somebody gives me attitude I have to
spit in there and a lot of people most
of the time
like everybody was really cool like
there was very few times where people
were really rude to me but everybody was
actually one time this one guy I was
giving him change for a soda I was
giving him change and then he tried to
give me more money so he can get better
change or I don't know what yeah yeah
yeah and then I was like oh sorry sir
like I really I just already you know
did the thing or whatever and he's like
oh like he looked him out crazy and I
was like all right and I gave him extra
change but it was at the time we would
have her bring her own change we
couldn't use the register yeah so way to
use her own change and then he looked at
me and goes you know you gave me extra
change right and I'm like yeah it's all
right no worries like oh it's it's a
rush like I gotta get you out I was like
don't worry about it it's all good and
he goes well does your manager know that
you're taking on I was like I was like
oh well it's actually for my change so
it's all good your face yeah okay I was
like sounds like oh it's all good and he
go he looks at me like really disgusting
and he goes you know I thought Asians
would be good at math oh [ __ ]
why didn't you stab him on the spot and
I hold him by his neck like so was his
wife I wish I had Corona oh yeah I don't
dine too weak I looked at him and I was
like haha but I'm not and I just let
happened but it was cool cuz the people
at the bar that were sitting at the bar
that saw everything that went down they
like looked at me they're like oh I'm so
sorry and I was like whatever and they
made they [ __ ] tip me out I love it
afterwards I was like in the moment I
was like yeah whatever [ __ ] that guy but
like five minutes passed and I was like
yo [ __ ] that dude bro and I actually
went outside and it was dumb but I kind
of went outside to like kind of like
look I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
gonna do [ __ ] probably nick has his
thumbs like this I was like hey what's
up dude and I wasn't gonna do [ __ ] I
liked working jobs like that though
because of interactions like that so I
growing up I'd always hear about like oh
I worked in here and I had this crazy
person like you're just waiting for that
[ __ ] thing I loved it it was so fun one
of those you want yeah I wanted to see
like how people react in there there was
like the bad ones and the funny ones
right I remember one of the ones that
annoy me the most is we used to sell
bags of ice at Burger King really yeah
because the public is you nares known as
hot as [ __ ] yeah so yeah you could buy
bags of ice there right which was kind
of annoying because was that normal in
Arizona
yeah I think so I thought you could like
this
an actual bird you worked at a bodega oh
my god
it was like yeah it's called ketchup if
you look at the bottle this is ca am I
not my technically is called meat prints
but we good no but what's it called so
we used to sell bags of ice and a lot of
place to do like Sonic and share either
sell bags of ice really mm-hmm
I don't know he went out here unhappy
Arizona yeah but they also sell tires of
[ __ ] that'll change that so this [ __ ]
right she comes up to the drive-thru I'm
like eh how can it can I take your order
she this is a question verbatim what do
your what does your ice come in and I
say comes in bags no [ __ ] [ __ ]
Sherlock and I and everybody in the
kitchen turns and goes because like and
and I don't know about every fast-food
but it has intercoms even for the steak
right - so you can do it and I look at
everybody was just looking at me I'm
like excuse me yeah what does your bags
of ice come in I don't need a smartass
remark I'm like it comes in bags she's
I'm [ __ ] coming to the window she
comes to the window and I'm like I'm
sorry I guess there's a confusion she's
like yeah there is
I'm asking you what your [ __ ] bags of
what you're out what your ice comes in
and you have it you think it's funny to
say bags I mean exactly I'm like but
you're asking me what it comes in it
comes no like what does it come in like
packs of two or what I'm like oh that's
a different question I said that's
exactly what I said she I need to speak
to your manager so I call him over there
turn my hat around this last night hello
manager yeah so she comes over and he's
like oh what's he's like what's going on
he's like yeah your your employee has an
attitude and he was like you know you
know ma'am like I heard your question
over the intercom you asked what ice
comes in he answered in the bags he's
like you know she's like oh so you're
gonna have a smartass remark - it was
like this big ordeal and then she dips
out [ __ ] just pull you should have
pulled the the AT&T thing that we
experienced were like Hawaiian the
manager and the manager talked about 18t
real quick yeah yeah these [ __ ]
have the worst customers this podcast is
brought to you by 18
bro we we went this way this guy came
with me on the door and we're
experiencing some billing issues with
AT&T through Tiff's plan or whatever and
they kept probably they said they're
gonna credit our bill yada yada yada and
they just kept like ducking us bro they
were passing us around different people
like oh yeah like oh the billing cycle
isn't up yeah yeah yeah they came up
with every [ __ ] excuse in the bag and
every time you wanted to talk to the guy
the manager that that would allow us to
do the credit or ever they would get
passed off to this other guy like oh I'm
actually the manager yes the 18t store
has 15 managers bro so I went with him
because I worked at Best Buy right so I
kind of know how mobile works is I was I
was an apple specialist and I was a
mobile specialist I did both so I was
telling him I'm like no basically what's
happening is that the guy doesn't want
to come and talk to you bro yeah that's
what I was telling him because every
time so remember they even came a point
I asked him I'm like yo so then why did
he tell us to come at work the dude told
us to go back the next day at one
o'clock to get a confirmation from the
manager who authorized this credit yeah
so I even say because it happened like
three times and this how I knew they
were [ __ ] with him because one of the
guys that came up and talked to us at
the end it was the guy said that too
he even told the other employees I'm
going to lunch I heard him say that yeah
so he's going in the back and stuff they
come out he said oh he's not gonna be
able to talk to you cuz he's on a call
and he's gonna be for a while
so I even say this not even my ordeal
I'm just going there with Nick because
you're there I'm like so why did he say
to come at 1:00 if he was gonna take a
phone call that was gonna be an hour at
1:00 yeah bro and he was like oh yeah
he's gonna be free a1 come back dude it
was the most and I wanted to sock all
the holes I wanted all the some and then
the guy has attitude one of the guys who
and I hope your set guy has an attitude
and I'm just looking at him like oh my
cuz I know this just I worked in retail
and I'm after I was ten I'm like no Nick
basically what it is is they don't want
to [ __ ] talk to you I know this from
Brody's been dealing with this shift
since December bro yeah what how much
damn money they owe you they owed us
like two hundred like two hundred
[ __ ] there's all this a lot of money
yeah and it was it was insane like the
the amount of [ __ ] and disk
expect these fools lay it out on us was
insane dude and unless I did tell I
would go on with TIFF and I would tell
TIFF like yo stop with attitude because
she was so super pissed yeah
and I had to tell like yo like you
yelling at that or you getting really
upset and worked up and telling this guy
your problems with another manager and
you kind of like getting mad at this
dude isn't gonna help the situation
yeah but then afterwards I was like yo
are you [ __ ] kidding me he go there he
goes what the [ __ ] yeah yeah and I was
like oh I want to punch all these dudes
face cuz the way they talk to you is
like we're [ __ ] dumb like yeah like
no no no we know how we know what what
this is people people are so [ __ ] odd
man like it's it's just hard sometimes
like I wonder if how many of these
people have ever been punched in the
face that's what it is dude and they
think that they're they work and
honestly it's like customer service
should not be that way because we've all
been in customer service and we
understand what it is to have their job
so it's like I've never done that this
guy this guy was telling us like oh well
we can't give too much credit over the
month because you know it looks bad on
our store and then we can't get it's not
my problem bro you can't get we can't
get promotions and I'm like hey dude
you're I'm sorry but you promised us
this you don't work there oh dude I
don't matter to you sorry and I I wish
it was different circumstances cuz then
we wouldn't have wasted all this time at
this goddamn store and we knew all the
guys that worked there bro I literally
knew it I met everybody on staff and
they all right when we walked in they're
like oh what's up dude the only dude
that was like chill with us was this one
Armenian dude with glasses who was like
a man I'm sorry and then the one that
was trying to like hook us up yeah he
was trying to do and the one little tiny
guy that was being a [ __ ] really rude
[ __ ] the guy that came in when I saw
that guy at Shake Shack like a couple
weeks ago and I looked at him and he was
like he looked at me he knew where I was
from she's gonna [ __ ] them up that is it
bro I was like any burgers without teeth
but I know that like I said from
experience that's the whole thing and I
was telling them that I'm like this the
reason why this is such an issue is
because it's going to affect somebody
it's either like a bonus you know cuz I
had a lot of these places like the more
sign ups and more [ __ ] add-ons you do
which is good what hap
and it looks good on you which can
affect a bonus and that's our [ __ ] and
when you have to take it away it looks
bad yeah so that's what I was telling
all it is is this is affecting someone
that's why they're trying to do
everything in their power to do it
some way they're trying to figure out a
different way to do it when all they
should have to do is pretty simple go in
and refund it yeah yeah that's it's
pretty simple in that sense but there's
a lot of ways to do [ __ ] to get around
this where you don't have to do that
where it looks like that yeah but that's
all they were doing they were just
[ __ ] with you and that III know it's
obvious to you at the Hastings village
yeah Pasadena no but I feel like I was
overall dude I've always been a good a
sales person yeah because I think
because of how I am so I've always been
nice even what if you were mad it even
came to a point where sometimes like at
my old store I used to work out in
Arizona I wasn't even a manager
supervisor or anything but they used to
actually let me go and talk to ya like
supervisor to BIA Alex can you go talk
to this person because you have to be
calm and cool and collected but you if
you show any sign of like well you're
being rude to the customer like it's all
professional yes yes which I do credit
Best Buy cuz a lot of these stores when
I go to them I'll see their customer
service and I'm just like yo like I
don't know how the [ __ ] these people
have jobs right for ROS my old store we
were so strict on everything like
everything had to be but if I were to
wear these shoes they would have gave me
a marker and said hey you can fill these
in or you can go home and change your
shoes
that's how strict they wear they had to
be all black well that all depends on
you on your management who runs stores
because exactly starts the table so it's
like you know it depends on who the
management and who's hiring because it's
like when I worked at the Men's
Wearhouse every Men's Warehouse was
different depending on who was running
it yeah majority of Best Buy's have been
to have been hot trash though exactly so
that's what I'm saying trash when I came
when I came out here is Best Buy yeah
when I came out here so I my old store
they send it to us send us to induction
training where they're teaching you how
to sell and build a rapport with
customers and all that type of stuff we
were super strict on customer comes into
your section they need to be contacted
within 30 seconds of them entering in
and literally our supervisors are
watching us to make sure that we're
doing these things as if not they would
talk to you pull you aside make sure you
doing it so when I when I moved out here
cuz I was a salesperson
I was in some things like branded
payment which is credit card apps I was
top in I was really good at sales I had
a lot of top numbers but when I moved
out here it was super fast like my move
out here was very unexpected to a lot of
people I had to just try to fit pick any
job I could so I ended up out here as a
merch part-time merch so when I did they
didn't really know what my sells so I
would sit there and watch some of these
people sell and how they were
interacting with customers I'm like
Howard how are these stores like
functioning yeah these people have zero
customer service it's so crazy it's like
the way some people act is like you thus
the people that work at the store like
you the customer owes you yeah a type of
[ __ ] like it's hard because like
number one it's like I said it's about
how you hire hire staff oh yeah so a lot
of times when people look at part-time
jobs specifically this is a problem in
college students cuz we had this problem
with our sponsors right college students
are the hardest people to hire in the
reason why is because they are in
college and they're going for a degree
for sub for a job that's bigger in the
future so they think that the job that
they work at right now is beneath them
yeah it's like that so yeah that's
that's how they treat these retail jobs
and also to conversely some of these
jobs like Best Buy unless you have
somebody who's a good managers that can
relate to the employees why it's
important to be a good worker it's not
gonna happen because it's top-down and
number two there's no incentives at Best
Buy yeah so originally for even
something I like the Men's Wearhouse
there was before it acquired this other
place called something tuxedo I forgot
what it was but I was in tuxedo I think
I think I know what you are yeah the
tuxedos well I think yeah friar Tuck's a
friar Tuck's is one of the one that they
acquired for the old man's warehouse yes
so they also acquired something else
they they Felix or something like that
they're you know but they basically for
every rental that we did in around prom
time we would get an X amount of
Commission so let's say I rent it out
like a $200 tux I'll get $20.00
Commission on this [ __ ] 100 something
dollars that I would get a $10
Commissioner it's great so we would we
would [ __ ] hustle our asses off
because of that incentive Best Buy
people who are sales people they don't
get a [ __ ] cut of anything I know
Commission something small right like
anything would be great and they would
push these sales even harder
no incentivization I don't know how it
works from the top down maybe they
figured out that it doesn't really help
but that's also because of the people
that you hire like if you hire good
people that are motivated then your
store actually does better anything than
great incentives because it was like
when I worked at a restaurant I knew
that if I did a really good job for my
tables I would get a nice tip or not
right it's it's very you don't know but
you'd rather give shoot your shot and be
the best you could be for that table and
provide the grace the best service you
can to that table so if you do get a tip
that's awesome if you don't then you're
like alright well I did what I could
there's nothing else I could do people
even have a problem with like tipping
culture too because they're like in the
state's they're like well we some people
don't believe in tips other people
believe that you know the waiter should
be paid a great wage so they shouldn't
have to receive tips I think okay your
[ __ ] you're gonna get the Rona this will
tour his glove Jesus - but the problem
with that is like hands this is this is
the issue - that a lot of people don't
get right so let's say we raise minimum
wage we wait we wait we wait we wait we
raise minimum wage to about let's say 16
dollars an hour great these people can
make a living and they can live a good
life here's the problem though what they
don't realize - when these small
businesses they don't make a lot of
money and they raise they raise minimum
wage to 16 bucks for everybody guess
what half the staff is firing on and now
there's no more part-time workers and
everybody's full-time yeah and so
they're like well why are we getting
fired because we can't afford you now so
now not only do you work full time and
you'll have to work longer hours now you
have to be worth that 16 dollars so the
requirement for your job now I'm sorry
isn't just that the fact that you're up
you're 16 and you're capable I'd rather
take the dude that has I don't know like
experience a college degree I'll take
you instead because I know for a fact
that you are gonna work those 16 dollars
an hour and you're gonna work really
really well so there's there's there's
an issue with this too because a lot of
people are like well I'm a waiter I
deserve this stuff that's true however I
agree that you do work hard so you're
gonna get paid that but the other
workers who don't they're also gonna get
fired so real dude
I think incentives are big though - you
know I despise I'd like to be a
disincentive I don't I don't know I
gotta own a business or anything but
like personal example right
yeah when I worked at Best Buy there's
something called branded payments right
which is credit card apps and I know I'm
good at talking to people when I need to
so like you know if I don't know B what
I'm going to talk to them but if I'm in
a professional setting I can talk to
absolutely anybody doesn't matter to me
so I was really good at talking to
people getting people to apply for the
Best Buy credit card in that type of
stuff so for about seven months I was
top of our store and I started getting
into like top of our district in the top
of our territory right because I would
have liked
throughout the month forty to fifty
people applying for credit cards every
single month because I knew how to
explain it to specific people I know how
to explain it different ways to kind of
people get people's mind wrapped around
how it's gonna benefit them right so
then they started doing this thing
called induction training right for
these credit card apps I got nothing
right and it was just like part of my
job whatever okay it's part of my job I
got to do it that's how I've always
worked mm-hmm so I go to this induction
training I was an apple lead so there's
something happened to our store where
normally they wanted three people from
each store to go together all the time
all this you know not all the sudden but
something happened to where I had to go
by myself so we go to this induction
training and I'm we're sitting in our
store like blocks right and I have
nobody so I'm sitting at someone else's
table the induction persons talking
whatever we do class and then they ask
like oh so let's see who the the stores
are in right they start listing off
stores and everybody's raising their
hands and they're like my store I raised
my hand oh you're here by yourself
I explained it later on we get down to
branded payments right so I'm last like
I'm in the back right sitting by myself
they asked like oh so what do you what
do you guys get for getting branded
payments right someone's like oh we get
a we get a drink every time we get one
another store oh we get our tickets we
get them we get tickets every time and
at the end of the week we put it in and
we grab we get a raffle prize right and
then other that [ __ ] just kept adding up
like oh we at the end of the month it
goes into this or this if you get a
surmount you get lunch right it gets to
me they're like she's all Alex what do
you get I'm like I get nothing yeah
everybody starts laughing and she's like
no what do you really get I'm like I
literally
I get nothing she's like aren't you like
top in territory I'm like yeah so
immediately right when I heard that
right my performance on my work change
right I went back to work like yeah why
am I trying so [ __ ] hard to get it
all these other stores are getting it
right and it's funny because when you
know a lot of places like this when you
do a certain amount of work right and
you over exceed they just expect that
from you all the time so I dropped from
getting 50 every month to like 20 or 15
and like after the first month it was
already an issue where they come and
they talk to me they're like hey so
what's going on I'm like yo I'm not
gonna lie went to this induction
training I had to go by myself
everybody knew that every store had the
list of [ __ ] that they get forgetting
the certain amount of credit card apps
they're like yeah I was like we get
nothing dude and I'm over here busting
my ass trying to purposely get him
I'm getting an insane amount every month
I was like and this is seven months
straight and I've gotten zero for me I
haven't got a raise
I've got nothing from this but all these
other stores that's why they're trying
to get it so much I was like look and
they're getting so much they're they're
they're I mean they're getting all this
stuff and they're not they're still not
even getting as much as me yeah I'm like
so like it kind of bummed me out but
that ended up changing it for the store
so like the week after that it was if
you guys get to credit apps in the day
you guys get a free drink or if you get
something like this you do this if you
get a specific amount and all the sudden
of course right our [ __ ] credit apps
I'm not the only one that's getting
[ __ ] all the credit apps people are
starting against amount and it's even
out I was still getting a lot I was
really good at it
and it was funny too cuz there was
points in times where the store was slow
one of the managers but all right if
someone gets five credit apps today a
bomb free lunch oh my [ __ ] I get free
lunch today I was straight up get five
credit apps right yeah and I will do
that type of [ __ ] and then I remember
one time they they asked me do I a we
want you to teach a class on how to do a
credit apps branded payments and stuff
I'm like there's not that much to teach
like what do you mean I'm like you just
ask everybody just tell it just tell
everybody right and I remember game yeah
but it's literally like you have to tell
everybody and so I remember went to
class in this one fool I remember his
name - I ain't gonna say his name
can hate him and he smelled like [ __ ]
right was his name just say it no lips
almost at it it was it was like Robin
but ketchup they had me teach this class
and I'm already like I don't wanna
[ __ ] do this right like everybody
knows how to do this [ __ ] why do I need
to teach it right so we get there and I
was already heated because I had to get
there out of like [ __ ] 7:00 in the
morning I was tired I get there and the
[ __ ] like alright so what are
you gonna bother with us today I was
like [ __ ] maybe if you knew how to
[ __ ] get a credit app you wouldn't
have to be here yeah that's shitty every
[ __ ] so the manager Mazar Alex I'm like
dude I don't want to deal with the [ __ ]
I'm like this kids [ __ ] annoying
anyways yeah how long I do it there
right sorry going this guy knows you
don't like him yeah I don't know I never
talked to him he's one of those guys
best spot has like 80 employees or his
name so basically I'm gonna get that man
but um so I remember telling them and
they're like so what what is the
technique I like you just ask everybody
and that same kid I do I'm like
obviously you don't cuz you're here
right yeah it's like how do you ask them
to yeah well I can't believe that guy
and so he would literally ask me they
asked me like give us an example I was
like okay as a mystery frog no his name
is howler monkey so he they asked me
like give us an example so the the
person I was like alright so a customer
walks in I see them I give him about
five to ten seconds to walk around and
start looking and I want to immediately
bombard him right when they get in there
right so doesn't feel like oh [ __ ] you
did this motion so you punch them yeah
so they in the back and they do I said
hey guys how you guys doing today
whatever like that right they say oh
we're good and then it goes to the point
like oh did you guys have any questions
you guys looking for anything specific I
could help out with and they say no
right I was like so what's everybody's
normal reaction don't like oh we would
sit there and be like okay well let us
know if you have questions or try to
small start small talk and most of the
time to be like that I was like my
reaction is okay cool well just so you
know if you guys are looking around that
stuff we do have a branded payment we
have a credit card if you wanted to get
some extra stuff this would give you
this much of interest no interest
financing that type of stuff
just so you guys know about it while
you're looking at stuff so you can have
that in you
mind to where I want to get this I don't
have enough money today but maybe I can
try for that credit card I was like
that's what I did even if someone said I
want zero help I made sure that okay
cool we'll just so you know we do have a
vent best by credit card in case you're
interested in that we give this no entry
friend you know what the hard part about
Best Buy is the reason why I always say
I don't need help is because you don't
know anything
yeah like would you like any help I'm
like from you you don't know [ __ ] but
that's the problem is like you get these
people that love unqualified low key
some people actually know a lot of [ __ ]
but high key a lot of people die exactly
I went when I was looking for I was
looking for something very specific
right and there was oh it was a I'm
sorry that wasn't bad specific but it
was a it was an SD card right but it was
I needed an SDXC card right guy nobody
knew what a [ __ ] SDXC card they're
like this I was like no that's it
doesn't have a fast read rate but yeah
that's like the higher end ones for like
these types of care exactly what the
[ __ ] I was talking about and I was like
I need it to be SD xc2 and they're like
I don't know what that is I was like
Doug this is your department yeah bro
you'll see the price difference too and
also yeah so just look those letters do
that that's the thing
so honestly when I first started there I
didn't know [ __ ] like I was in computers
I was just good at selling [ __ ] right so
like computers all I did and this is the
whole thing it's like people don't like
to do research and [ __ ] but best buy
they literally worked up on it they have
cards and it literally would explain
everything in the computer but at the
same time it's like I go a little extra
with jobs right so I would purposely go
to Geek Squad and talk to me Oh what
does this do what does this do what does
this you because I don't want to sound
like an idiot right building someone's
like looking for someone like yeah those
people in sales though like they they
try to do the it's the sales tactic
that's right and but there's a lot of
people like for example like me I
probably already know about the stuff
that I'm looking for more than you do
right so for example when I went to go
buy so I got a new car recently right
and so I want to go at the 4runner now
the sales guys really nice very very
[ __ ] nice guy right me on the other
hand I know what I want I know how much
I want to pay if I want to sit there and
haggle out for the next three to four
hours I could probably get the price
that I would I would
yeah but I don't have that time my car
broke down I mean I needed a car to that
Honda Element that she rest in peace
that car was such a piece of [ __ ] I even
had the back seats in I said I'm gonna
come and bring that back for you guys he
said it doesn't rap I was like I'm gonna
break and I brought it over and they're
like we don't have any use for this you
can just put it there disrespect bro but
once you go get this [ __ ] car right
and you know he's like on his salesmen
tactics so this is what they first do I
first of all the the price of the car
what I can get for the lease obviously
they don't they don't really incorporate
the tax and whatever all the other [ __ ]
right hmm it's um it's online you just
calculate it out and you can see how
much you can get it for for a lease I'm
not really gonna buy it well this one
I'm probably gonna buy at the end so
that's why I didn't really care yeah
because it's gonna take away from the
value of the car at the end of it as
long as the interest rate is fine so I
went there and he goes all right he goes
all right bro this is what I could do
army guy of course this is what very
nice guy very nice guy oh this is what I
can do for the car for at least mmm we
can do about 920 a month I was like for
a forerunner I was like excuse me I was
like not $1,000 a month I was like bro I
owned a Tesla that's almost as much as
my Tesla are you kidding me I was like
listen this is this is what it is I need
to get this car in 45 minutes
all right and I need this car today so
or I can come back to money goes no I
can only give you a good deal today I
was like that's I I look at my way
that's not true
yeah but who's ever believed exactly I
was like that's I was like that's not
true
but this is what it is I want to spend
about $700 in this car max which by the
way I told him if I cattle this out with
you and I went to a different Toyota I
could probably get this for like about
600 500 bucks a month but I'm telling
you 700 right now just because I have a
feeling that it's gonna buy this car at
the end of the day anyways I just wanted
to get at least right now is better for
tax right yeah so the guy comes up he
goes okay let me talk to my manager I
was like bro there she is oh no [ __ ]
man
I legitimately eyes I said there is no
manager you're gonna go back nothing's
gonna happen you're gonna pretend and
you're trying to keep me here longer I
said 45 minutes once that 45-minute mark
hits I'm out so don't talk to a manager
egos okay
you see what I could do he goes back he
goes back comes back ten minutes later
he goes what I can do is about eight
hundred I was like I just told you seven
hundred or No Deal so and I started
getting up miles like all right bro I'm
gonna leave he was like okay let me let
me talk to my man I was like there is no
manager secretly he goes back I see this
back suit his ass is just sweating
through my cologne is even stronger yeah
the colognes not working on it I don't
understand his senses fine tiny little
Asian nose but he he comes back and so I
was just so irritated at this point I
was like all right this is what it is
I'll lease it for four years right four
years twelve thousand miles and then
we'll do it for about like 755 I'm okay
with that I was like it's already way
more than it's worth it's probably a
hundred dollars more than I can get it
for but let's just get this sign out and
go he goes all right man like I'll see
what I was like you know you can do it
this is not a good deal this is an
average average [ __ ] deal because I
got it foreign that's kind of like the
top tier yeah and so and they kind of
like overpriced a little hard to come
back and and he's about to leave the
model that I have comes with a Yakima
roof rack right and as he's leaving he
goes he goes I'll see if I could get you
that roof rack too I was like bro it
comes with the model yeah it turns back
he goes are you a [ __ ] salesman er no
cuz I just I need to know I see my dad
do this already so when I got my when I
bought got the Jeep from my parents I've
seen my dad haggle he doesn't take [ __ ]
they need to sell these cars yeah and
and it's not like I'm asking for a great
deal I'm asking if you want to go home
with money in your pocket dude exactly I
was like Jesse I want the Commission
like what do you want do I I worked at a
car dealership for two weeks I didn't
like it literally had every job I know
but I didn't like it because of that so
Best Buy is not Commission right yeah so
it's a little easier even though people
still act like it's Commission on a lot
of spots right because they do watch
like your notional margin and that's up
yeah right but when I went into the car
sales I did it for two weeks I'm like
yeah this isn't for me because you could
just see number one like all those
people there were dicks like because I
was like the youngest sales person there
because what it was is my old supervisor
got let go from Best Buy because they
did a restructure
he went there and he kept asking me like
hey yo come and work for me over here
come and work for me over here cuz he
knows how I sell I went that I did it
for two weeks and I was the youngest guy
all these other guys were [ __ ] old and
they were all like [ __ ] and I was
like I just want to beat the living [ __ ]
out of every single one of these guys
right here all dicks number one but then
it was like yeah it's like I didn't I
wasn't a huge fan of the Commission
thing and I think it's like a certain
amount of sales that you get and then
the Commission starts being exactly a
because some some spots have base pays
and then if you end up selling more than
your base pay you get more than your
base pay but if you don't then you get
the base pay that's a good dealership
some delicious don't do that some
dealerships it's only Commission that's
a tough gig yeah it is it's it's you
know I'm not saying I was too hard but
it's kind of too hard in the sense of
like it's like I wanna be Wanna saying
like most people don't think that they
have to be knowledgeable about the stuff
because I feel like a majority people
who come to buy a product they're very
the Lehman's they don't understand a lot
of the stuff yeah and so like when I was
talking to him about the car I I was
laying down everything that I like about
this fall didn't know [ __ ] about the
[ __ ] vehicle is like he goes out
there after a while he just like I don't
know about this stuff and I'm like
because I was asking him just to see if
he knew I was like so the new ones come
with an adaptive cruise control he goes
no I was like I know there's all the
four runners there's still the same I
was like not what the twenty that guy
had the worst experience because when
David goes deep on something he goes
[ __ ] this dude is in the wormhole but
all like with four runners that's why I
was good at selling because I cared
right yeah like I if you came in and I
wasn't scared to do this if someone came
and asked me questions and I didn't know
I was never scared to be like you know
what I don't know let me check alright I
can see let me look for you
I was never scared to do that was
genuine - yeah and that was my thing and
I used to hear people lie and [ __ ] like
just make up [ __ ] and I'm listening to
them like you know why why are you doing
this this person because you're lying
there most likely going to come back
it's not like a pleasant visit when they
come back right but that was my thing
and usually like if I like [ __ ] that's
not like the people that easy into yeah
like if I cuz I was an apple specialist
right but I loved apples so I knew how
to use apples so that's why I was Apple
specialist because I know how to use it
usually by like [ __ ] - I mean I could
sell a [ __ ] out of it right
and I usually try to get people to buy
[ __ ] all the time like [ __ ] remember
these shorts and she's told us the other
day
look he's the worst salesman ever though
because he just does it by force as well
by this dude by this is full amount this
guy has pressed a deep-fried sushi roll
on me is the most offensive this was
like this trial has been about like I
don't know damn near a year and he
finally got to got me to eat that mango
I don't you do we're on people huh I'm
good at it dude I'm telling you I could
sell I was okay this dude was he was
showing us these new shorts that target
the all motion or something I was there
yesterday and I was going just to bite
duct tape that was literally the only
thing I was gonna buy your boy was in
the all motion section for like 15-20
minutes like oh man is this the one that
Alex has I got three shorts and three
shirts I know I'll tell you what if I
like something I will get people to
[ __ ] go to it like they were really
good shots my chiropractor Oh
because I like him I try to send
everybody to so can I say something
about that
so when you were telling me about your
chiropractor I was always like alright
whatever you know yada yada yada I went
the last day of our marathon training I
did with Bart and my knee just will gave
out like it just hurts so bad and he
goes yo dude like you should talk to
this one guy he's a sports guy he really
likes working with like athletic
populations he's a chiropractor he's in
Monterey Park as soon as I said Monterey
Park in my head I was like if this is
the same guy that Alex was talking about
I'm gonna jump off a bridge
I'm sure enough he's like yeah yeah he
was talking him up he's like he's he
does like two hours with you he won't
let you leave till you're fixed yada
yada yada he pulls up the Yelp it's the
same [ __ ] guy I gotta go to this guy
man yeah we gotta go let's go I'm
telling ya he's worth it dude I'm sure
he's free now like you know he's still
working right yeah he's I think I don't
know I think's places like that or still
there's only like one person yeah yeah
like Oh food - our food spots and [ __ ]
you know um oh if I like him and I'll
try to sell it bro you should be the
number one salesman for Howland Ray's
that'd be perfect
hey shout out hey sponsor day let's talk
about this they'll [ __ ] this guy because
at first of all in the beginning of the
year we all did a weight loss bet right
this [ __ ] the next day we
trained he came hey yeah powdered donut
powder on his lips I was like dog what
are you eating he goes because I had to
get me some breakfast like literally
just did the bet yesterday could I could
have Kuwait cuz the corona boy okay you
try [ __ ] holidays you mean the fried
chicken sandwich but doesn't give a [ __ ]
about I think you gain weight during the
week hey Loki kind of did a coronavirus
thanks for saving me bad because of the
genius brain podcast if you guys want to
watch this first of all you can check
them out at the big mad podcast
yeah that's Alec cause the that's Alex
dot was it GG f GG f and you can find
Nick at Nick to the ear on Instagram you
can find this podcast everywhere as you
can tell this podcast is podcast I'm
[ __ ] up my English it's all pure
nonsense we're just there to keep you a
busy on your commute and just chop it up
with you and just make sure you're not
bored oh yeah during the quarantine bet
you this podcast is poppin see y'all
next time peace but